this morning as we continue highlighting
the best new books every week david
sedaris
the best of me is sedaris's handpicked
collection of his favorites
it is hilarious touching and crass some
of the odd enduring qualities that have
made him so famous over the years
before the pandemic he was the only
author we knew of who could fill concert
venues just so
people could listen to him read out loud
during the pandemic david sedaris is
still finding things to laugh about
starting with zoom thank you for not
doing a zoom interview
well i i did one
but my policy was to do none but
and it wasn't that satisfying is it for
anyone
i think some lazy people prefer it like
they say oh you don't have to wear pants
and you have to leave the house and i
think how lazy can you get
david sedaris's writing has changed over
the years
did i tell you about the burglar who got
stuck in the chimney
but he has never lost his brutal sense
of humor
so who was this burglar i'd ask did they
identify his body
he was a gypsy a drifter and on two
occasions
an arab this is the first time sedaris
has performed for someone
in person since the pandemic began he
met us in new york's central park
it's also the first time he signed his
much sought-after personalized copies of
books in months
his newest collection is called the best
of me
one thing i realized is with this book
you can
add to the me and so you can have the
best of mexico
the best of mediocrity the best of
meningitis
sedaris's jokes have never been for
everyone but sometimes
based on the crowds you feel like it's
close
millions have found something special in
the way he's been writing about his life
and family for the last 30 years
he's produced 11 best-selling books
including barrel fever
naked and let's explore diabetes with
owls
most of those books have been followed
by sold out concert tours across the
country
at last night's signing i was approached
by a teenage girl who asked me to
autograph
what was without question the ugliest
t-shirt i had ever seen in my life
and even the occasional commencement
address choose
one thing to be terribly terribly
offended by this as opposed
to the dozens or possibly hundreds that
many of you are currently juggling
do you prefer performing in touring or
writing i always think of performing and
touring as my reward for writing
so it's my reward for being alone do you
miss touring
i miss it so much i miss even
delayed flights and crummy hotels
i i wonder if it's possible to die from
lack of attention
i i say to my boyfriend just applaud for
me i'm going to walk into the room and i
want you to applaud
i just miss it so much i miss
attention sedaris's early work focused
mostly on his childhood
he was born in upstate new york and
raised in north carolina
his mother who battled alcoholism died
when sedaris was in his early 30s
seven years ago his sister tiffany died
by suicide
a story included in the best of me which
he says is his favorite
because he got a chance to share the
toll of her mental illness
assadera's tradition of rarely holding
back feelings about family
he calls his father just shy of 100 and
recently recovered from a near-death
experience
cold and mean my father's 97
this is what people say oh like that
oh you're so lucky and so my father
can't be visited now in his assistant
living center right
so i write him letters and then
i talked to him a while ago and he said
i got those last two letters
you sure didn't have anything to say i
thought
who else is writing you nobody else is
writing you letters
that's how i know he was better you know
that he could just be
he could be mean i thought hey dad's
back
does your family like you well
i bought them a beach house so they
better like me i mean i think sometimes
people got the idea like oh i'm glad i'm
not in your family
but when i write something about my
family it's always something they know
is funny
you don't do social media i have a
facebook page but i've never looked at
it
and i think i have a twitter account
i've never looked at that either
and i think it makes me a happier person
this collection of essays represents
just a small body of his work
and will likely again hit the best
seller list but these days there's
something else
sedera says he wants to be remembered
for when he's not in new york
he and his partner hugh hamrick are at
their home in the english countryside
where sedaris picked up some work as a
volunteer
i was out riding my bike one day and i
saw a guy picking up rubbish and i said
uh
what are you doing and he said i'm
picking this up i said are you paid and
he said no it just drives me crazy
and i thought well i can do that so i
started doing it that very day
the town even recently named a dump
truck in his honor
i usually spend when i'm in england
between four and eight hours a day
picking up trash on the side of the road
and that's what you want
david or the david sedaris legacy to be
i'd be happy if that was it it gives me
an incredible
sense of accomplishment i think it's
more worthwhile than anything else that
i do
pretty cool huh four to eight hours a
day picking up trash on the side of the
road
david sedaris hates this word awesome
but he is awesome i i
just want to do this for him yes there
you go david we've been reading him
the whole family since the 90s and and
still do
and the writing has gotten more serious
um and more emotional so it's been
interesting to watch that journey for
him
yeah i hate litter bugs i'm all the way
i'm
coming over helping you pandemonium and
david working together
i'm out there that there it is and there
we go